we begin the program with the breaking
news israel's prime minister naftali
bennett and foreign minister yeah lapid
have agreed to dissolve parliament the
move is expected to force the country's
fifth election in less than three and a
half years lapid will take the role of
interim prime minister until the polls
for more on this let's bring in bernard
smith who joins us live from west
jerusalem bernard talk us through the
details of what's happened
this coalition government has been
stumbling along for the last few weeks
it's a miracle in many israelis eyes
that it's lasted as long as it has one
year it was the strangest coalition
government israel has ever seen a
combination of parties from the far
right the right the left and the first
time that uh palestinian israelis had
been involved in an israeli government
it was brought together this government
its sole reason for being really was to
get rid of benjamin netanyahu and it did
that and it managed also
to pass a state budget the first time
it's done that
in israel in three years but it's
benjamin netanyahu who has engineered
the downfall of this coalition
government he has been israelis prime
minister israel's prime minister for a
total of 15 years previously and he
wants the job back and what netanyahu
did was with his coalition opposition
partners he voted down the renewal the
normal standard automatic annual renewal
of a settler bill that extends israeli
law
into the settlements this expires at the
end of this month without its renewal
there's sort of legal chaos in the
settlement so the coalition governing
coalition realized that it's not going
to be able to get this bill passed so
they've accepted that they're going to
dissolve parliament and go to new
elections netanyahu gets what he wants
new elections and maybe the chance to
come back as prime minister and the
settler bill because the knesset is
being dissolved will be automatically
extended now for six months until a new
government can vote on it there'll be
elections now probably not before
sometime in october and ya lapid he will
take over
as interim prime minister while the
government goes through the process of
calling those new elections again the
fifth time in three and a half years
that they've had to have an election in
israel all right thank you so much for
bringing us up to speed bernard smith
live for us in west jerusalem also in
west jerusalem is jalal abu kata he's a
political analyst jalal thanks so much
for being on the program talk us through
firstly the turbulent weeks that have
led up to this point and the pressure
that the government has been under is it
any surprise that it's got to this point
sorry can you repeat the question please
i was just saying is there is it any
surprise that it's gotten to this point
let us lead us through what's led up to
this this point
yes uh it is no surprise i think from
the first moment this coalition came
into power last summer
it was seen to be very fragile and in
jerusalem especially palestinians in
jerusalem
[Music]
were worried were extroverted because
they felt this government was going to
try to prove its worth to the right of
the israeli electorate the right wing
the settler movement
those who would vote for usually for
netanyahu and wing parties this
coalition government tried its best to
become the government of the right to in
order to survive uh it's it's full term
uh lapid uh lapids was a very smart
politician i would say trying his best
to navigate the the intricate politics
of israel trying to get the left-wing
parties and those are considered the
merits
and other right-wing parties trying to
get them all to support his coalition
government trying to prove to israelis
that this government is the the
the solution for israel but everyone
knew that it was standing on a stick it
was um
it was
very close to collapse uh multiple times
over the past few months and we have
seen just now how the game of politics
in israel is so cynical the fact that
the israeli right-wing parties have
voted against extending this civil law
for for settlers in the west bank just
in order to topple the government and
yeah it was no surprise at all it is not
a shock at all that this government
could not even survive one whole year
jalal will this election change anything
or could israel still end up in the same
unstable position
um i
i don't i don't really believe it will
change anything as a palestinian
speaking i don't believe it will change
anything for israelis themselves they
there is a concern there is
warnings that a next government could be
bringing in netanyahu and bengavir into
the government it could bring in extreme
right wing um politicians into the
government uh which could
further um
damage israel's standing in the world
technically by uh
embracing apartheid more fully on and
strengthening settler movement uh which
would lead i would guess to isolating
israel on the international arena so
some israelis fear that
a government of the right would
further isolate israel globally so i
think there will be a stronger fight by
uh the the gov the government's uh
sorry the israeli parties which proclaim
to be liberal proclaimed to be uh
left-wing uh trying to win the
electorate again in order to oust
netanyahu for once and for all
to show that he is only a charlatan
trying to play politics
they will try to prove to to to israelis
that they are
more worthy than those who are cynical
in their politics game such as
the right-wing parties led by netanyahu
mainly and what does this move mean for
former prime minister benjamin netanyahu
could he form a coalition before
israelis even head to the polls
um i think
benjamin netanyahu is is better and
stronger at destroying and
demolishing
whatever other politicians
are able to to build and to establish
no one imagined the coalition government
that included right-wing parties uh the
labour party which is considered the
left-wing left zionist party merits and
the united arab list no one thought this
would be possible netanyahu was able
through
continuous bickering was able to topple
this government as we clearly see right
at this moment
um i i doubt i doubt that netanyahu
would be the one to form the next
government
we will see changes in israel i think
there will be
a similar government such as the one
we've seen now perhaps perhaps led by
benigns perhaps led by other
centrist zionist parties which could
unite more more of the israeli political
uh parties against this one person
netanyahu because he is seen to be a
destroyer rather than a builder of
coalitions
we really appreciate your analysis on
this issue jalal abu qatta a political
analyst in west jerusalem thank you
thank you very much